[Música]
a
gracias
hola muchas gracias bueno este es el
momento que llevaba esperando 25 años
como han dicho entre otras cosas he sido
profesor universitario tengo 500
personas aquí encerradas
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es un examen
y no os podéis escapar dar órdenes
severas de que nadie se mueva
pero la mala suerte no habéis pagado
qué le vamos a hacer así es la vida
bueno no es para tanto voy a poneros
aquí cinco preguntas de verdadero o
falso simplemente os pido que las leyes
y cada uno penséis si pensáis que es
verdadera es falsa
y después veremos lo que hacemos con
ellas atentos que me dan poco tiempo
la primera
la segunda
hay que pensar en espero que estamos a
buen café
la tercera
e inteligencia racional se refiere
y la quinta
bueno ahora lo importante claro las
notas porque claro sin notas y sin
evaluación esas cosas numeritos hay que
ponerle numeritos las notas bueno pues
si os obsesionan las notas son todas
falsas
nadie se marcha porque alguna hora
pecado seguro no tremendo placer mentira
bueno son todas falsas bajo cierto
modelo mental bajo cierta forma de
pensar
y el objetivo que tengo el humilde
objetivo que tengo hoy es dejaros muchas
preguntas no daros respuestas
utilizaremos las respuestas en las que
desde nuestra metodología y nuestra
forma de hacer creemos pero el objetivo
insisto es dejarlos muchas preguntas de
acuerdo bueno pues vamos con la primera
y más preguntas no hace más que
preguntar ya nos contar algo
alguien podría decir si se considerara
peso mundo humor
como alguien levante la mano se me
fastidió la charla bueno
bueno vamos a ver quiénes son estos
señores esa mujer que está ahí se llama
margaret mead precursora de la
antropología como ciencia a primeros del
siglo 20 investigó en muchas culturas en
concreto sobre todo en la zona nueva
guinea y dos de las más características
fueron los los árabes y los mundo humor
fijaros qué características tenían los
árabes
su foco central era el desarrollo
emocional de las personas y
particularmente el de los niños todo
giraba en torno a eso toda su energía en
esencia la ponían en torno a eso ya al
lado tenían a los mundo humor la foto es
real fijaros cómo trata esa mujer a su
pobre hijo
porque de hecho textualmente margaret me
describía que amamantaban a los niños a
la carrera y consideraba que los niños
molestaban que eran un estorbo
lo interesante de la cuestión es que la
distancia entre los árabes y los mundo
humor físicamente eran 160 km nada más
en consecuencia si se demuestra eran
genéticamente idénticos genéticamente
idénticos ahora bien como podemos
observar el comportamiento es digamos
que diferente verdad
bueno ahora os pregunto una de las
preguntas que os lanzo es que os
consideráis arab en el mundo como es
individual de que nadie conteste pero
guardar los da por favor para vuestra
reflexión
bueno algo más cercano porque alguien
puede decir bueno sí pero esto fue hace
un siglo
no sé si conocéis la estadística el
indicador o cde que mide la confianza
responde a una pregunta es muy simple
pregunta a ciudadanos de diferentes
países si confían en los que le rodean
en sus conciudadanos
me imagino que todos os habéis puesto a
buscar españa país vasco
y me imagino que todos estaréis con
ganas de saber cuál es la estadística
vale esta estadística al menos hasta
donde tenemos conocimiento lleva 14 años
prácticamente igual
ahora la pregunta es el factor confianza
es importante para innovar o no es
importante para innovar qué casualidad
que países como dinamarca noruega
holanda suecia etcétera tengan tasas de
innovación altísimas
y qué casualidad que el resto
en fin lo dejamos ahí
esto por cierto también hacer el
ejercicio cuatro de cada cinco personas
que os rodean en cada cuatro de cuatro
de cada cinco personas que rodean no
confiéis en ellas
que lo sepáis
bueno y ahora otra pregunta la sociedad
en la que vivís es ahora peso mundo
humor cómo catalogaría es la sociedad
nuestra sociedad en la que vivimos
otra pregunta
bueno vamos con la segunda
bueno aquí tenemos que citar al doctor
eduard de ming el verde min si alguien
ha estudiado ingeniería economía
en concreto gestión de calidad total
sabe de quién hablamos bueno es el
doctor de ming anunció la regla del 95 5
y dijo que el 95 por ciento del
desempeño depende del sistema
entendiendo el sistema como los roles el
organigrama trabajo en equipo la
estructura en general y solamente el 5%
depende del individuo me la juego a que
aquí habéis contestado la mayoría
verdadero
bueno vamos con la tercera
esta es muy interesante quizá alguno
conozcáis porque se basa en un
experimento el experimento de la
universidad de stanford es un
experimento clásico que se lleva a cabo
a finales de los 60 en la universidad de
stanford en concreto en la facultad de
psicología en los sótanos el doctor
philip zimbardo
el recreo recrearon él y su equipo una
cárcel en los sótanos de la universidad
él experimentó lo que pretendía era
descubrir si la situación en concreto el
poder de la situación es decir si las
situaciones no se eliminan la libertad y
nos comportamos no de acuerdo a nuestra
libertad individual en tanto que
individuos sino que nos comportamos de
acuerdo a la situación
era muy sencillo estudiantes de
psicología divididos mitad carceleros y
mitad prisioneros se les daba ropa y
estaban 24 horas metidos dentro de la
cárcel
el experimento estaba diseñado para
durar quince días al sexto día hubo que
pararlo porque empezaba la violencia
física severa es decir personas que
siete días antes eran amigos compañeros
se tomaban cervezas juntos estudiaban
juntos compartían apuntes o discutían al
de siete días estaba un amigo pegando a
otro amigo simplemente porque en un
experimento y siendo estudiantes de
psicología y sabiendo que era un
experimento se les había dicho que eran
carceleros y que su amigo era prisionero
esto es publicidad subliminal
no sería mal momento pero espero que no
esté prohibido portero preguntado bueno
da lo mismo porque no es una incitación
a beber que tampoco estaría mal
sino simplemente es para dejarlos
declarado que un experimento similar se
llamó el juego de la cerveza y está en
un libro que se llama la quinta
disciplina de peter sing y que
básicamente demuestra lo mismo que el
experimento anterior de la cárcel de
stanford demuestra que el comportamiento
de los individuos no depende de ellos
como individuos sino que depende de la
estructura del juego el sitio o el
entorno en el que estén en experimentos
similares por dejarlos declarados no
tenemos tiempo de desarrollarlos pero
son muy interesantes son el experimento
de milgram por ejemplo o el experimento
desarrollado por solomon als en un
ascensor en el que anunció el paradigma
de la conformidad
bueno esta cuestión es nuclear de
acuerdo es fundamental en lo que
humildemente hoy os quiero transmitir
y atenta directamente contra
probablemente el sistema de creencias
que todos tenemos instalado y es que
somos libres somos libres somos
individuos libres tenemos la capacidad
de actuar y de acuerdo a nuestra
individualidad pues actuamos libremente
dicho de otro modo
mucho más fácil y que si algo os apetece
recordar de este rato es esta frase que
repetimos muchísimo
en los procesos de innovación que
trabajamos y es que la estructura
condicional comportamiento que como digo
es muy revolucionario porque atenta
directamente contra nuestra forma de
pensar en la que pensamos que somos
libres
si esto es cierto que parece que lo es
no actuamos de acuerdo a nuestro ser
individual sino que actuamos de acuerdo
a la estructura a la que estamos
bueno conocéis a estos señores tienen un
aspecto
con el tercero yo cada vez que le miro
digo no me gustaría que fuera mi jefe
pero
pero bueno tío listo era
bueno pues estos tres señores
simplificando mucho por favor esto que
nadie me lo coja literal son los
responsables de esa maravilla es una
cosa preciosa verdad que sí
hablando de creencias es espectacular
como las organizaciones de hoy en día
creen que tener una cosa como esa y con
cuantos más cuadritos mejor implica que
está todo muy bien organizado y que todo
funciona perfecto
se lo creen es una creencia en el asunto
es que luego esta experiencia demuestra
lo contrario bueno lo curioso del asunto
bueno son taylor fagioli webber que
seguro muchos conocéis vale lo
interesante del asunto es que estos
señores fueron realmente innovadores
porque fueron capaces de encontrar la
forma de organizar y desarrollar lo que
conocemos como la revolución industrial
organizando adecuadamente las
organizaciones para que funcionaran de
acuerdo a lo que claro hace un siglo
hacía falta
algo más de un siglo de hecho
pero claro
ahora en que nos encontramos nos
encontramos con que las organizaciones
dicen que quieren innovar
pero la estructura organizacional sigue
inalterada desde el siglo 19 es decir si
la estructura condiciona el
comportamiento es decir si nos
comportamos de acuerdo a la estructura
en la que estamos y la estructura
organizacional es como hace siglo y
medio
estaremos comportándonos cómo se
comportaban las organizaciones de hace
siglo y medio
por lo tanto si lo que quieres es
innovar necesitas de algún modo alterar
la estructura porque si no el
comportamiento no va a variar por
definición
bien y qué es lo que nos encontramos tan
guapos los 13
qué clase
algunos pensaréis que son diferentes son
esencialmente iguales estructuralmente
iguales bueno es mi hipótesis esto me
puede costar caro ya puestos bueno los
modelos organizacionales actuales en
muchísimos casos en un porcentaje muy
alto son cerrados punto clave y además
están basados en un modelo taylorista
autoridad individual jerarquía y élite y
eso nos lleva a que se despilfarre
talento siendo también muy interesante
que las organizaciones se empeñan en
ahorrar dinero y luego resulta que el
talento se les escapa por la ventana a
chorros
y te encuentras con que pasa esto
en los 15 años he tenido la suerte de
trabajar en lo que os he contado no os
podéis imaginar la de veces que he visto
eso en una organización un departamento
diciendo weekly moldes valverde a los de
al lado les vale pena jojojo feliz
idiota
pero esto no ves que estás en el mismo
barco pero claro la estructura
condiciona el comportamiento a mi
departamento le va bien a mí me va bien
y los de al lado haya cuidados
pues nos encontraremos en algún lado
bueno vamos con la cuarta
esta es
para mí especialmente bonita bueno un
equipo de mighty dirigido por la doctora
bully investigó si era posible que un
equipo un sistema humano tuviera
inteligencia inteligencia racional
colectiva dicho de otro modo si un
equipo compuesto por individuos normales
y corrientes podría ser superdotado en
el sentido más puro de la inteligencia
racional y demostraron que si cosa que
es una noticia excelente
ahora bien hacen falta tres factores
clave hay más pero los tres clave son
estos la sensibilidad social que cosas
no hay no hay que tener siete másteres y
cuatro doctorados no sensibilidad social
que significa me preocupas así de simple
me preocupa porque eres un ser humano
igual que yo
la igualdad participativa aclaró todas
las personas tienen talento y si
solamente despliegan su talento unos que
son los que en teoría saben como decía
taylor que son los que dirigen y el
resto no pues estamos despilfarrando
talento como decíamos antes y la tercera
es la mejor que tiene gracia que tenga
que venir el lema ya decirnos
claro la proporción de mujeres en el
equipo que cosas tiene que venir a
decirnos esto estaría bien que muchas
empresas del ibex-35 del standard and
poor 500 se lo hicieran mirar
porque los consejos de administración
en fin me empiezo a meter en fango os
vamos a seguir
se me da bien eso bueno por lo tanto
estamos hablando de dos paradigmas dos
formas de entender la realidad una el
equipo había que poner a las chicas del
athletic de remedio
versus el individuo
que no sé bien quién es
las que no sé bien quién es pero lo
vamos a dejar ahí por aquello de los
fangos vamos a seguir
bueno conceptualmente de lo que estamos
hablando es de esto de si trabajamos en
el concepto de inteligencia colectiva y
el talento colectivo o trabajamos en
lógica jerárquica que no nos olvidemos
tiene 120 años no quiere decir que no
sea necesaria lo que quiere decir es que
hay que ponerla en contexto eso es lo
que quiere decir
por lo tanto
de lo que hablamos o lo que planteamos
es en repensar y compartir creencias
pensar si realmente el concepto de
liderazgo que en lo personal lo tengo
que decir estoy perfectamente harto de
escucharlo por todos los sitios
liderazgo líderes liderazgo líderes que
es aburridísimo
cuando tiene realmente tiene 120 años de
historia y si nos ponemos a pensar que
quizás a las organizaciones las tenemos
que mirar en lógicas colectivas y en
lógicas de talento e inteligencia
colectivas y no tanto esa frase textual
de milberg con esa mirada egocéntrica
heroica e individualista del líder
bueno el concepto de las creencias lo
explicó muy bien bertara pnv y en el
fondo lo que viene a decir es que
vivimos en un mundo de creencias estamos
rodeados de creencias todo lo que
hacemos son creencias las estructuras
organizacionales son creencias las
sociedades son creencias las culturas
son creencias innovar por definición
implica algún nivel de ruptura con las
creencias existentes aunque sea un poco
innovar por definición implica algún
nivel de ruptura o de quiebre con las
creencias existentes por lo tanto es
fundamental aprender a identificar las
creencias ya ser capaz de cambiarlas de
algún modo
bueno vamos con la quinta porque algunos
estaréis preguntando
deja que ella no
digo yo porque aparte eso deja que a
suena como de pena
son gente malísima bueno la pregunta que
subyace a todo esto es si la cooperación
es un concepto genético o cultural
parece que con los árabes y los mundo
humor ha quedado bastante claro que es
cultural obviamente no estamos
predeterminados para ser competitivos ni
para querer destruir al otro en todo lo
que hacemos incluyo los semáforos gente
de los semáforos tiene que salir el
primero siempre es una cosa terrible y
si le puedes ganar 80 no le ganas 40 no
hay que destruir al otro que gana
bueno pues una experiencia de
cooperación que muchos conoceréis es el
concepto del software libre
en el qué
esencialmente los científicos de la
época de informativos pero científicos
al fin y al cabo fueron muy destructivos
la ciencia normalmente en general
consiste en que si yo descubro algo me
lo guardo me lo guardo para mi equipo lo
público yo etcétera y esta gente lo que
dijo fue no señor vamos a compartir todo
y se autodenominaban 'hackers' sus
principios bueno éste richard stallman
que fue el gurú del movimiento hacker y
que la verdad solamente mirando las
ganas de irse a tomar cervezas con el
que no
me encantaría hablar con este tipo bueno
los principios del software libre son
estos
estamos hablando de centenares de miles
de personas sin que exista un mando no
existe una jerarquía existe autoridad
pero es conferida no es impuesta nadie
impone su autoridad sino que se consigue
esa auto conferida digamos
y los principios son espectaculares me
quedo con los dos últimos no sé por qué
será
a lo mejor es porque el modelo
tradicional está basado en jerarquía es
autoridad y centralización
y lo que han demostrado los hackers que
es el nombre que se auto se
autoimpusieron y que después se ha
convertido en algo negativo y que espero
que a partir de hoy por lo menos los que
estamos aquí lo veamos diferente es
precisamente compartir toda la
información porque compartir la
información es la única manera de
mejorar y de conseguir innovar
además de eso hay otras acepciones de
hacker que seguramente no conocíais como
que por ejemplo es capaz de implantar
soluciones para cualquier sistema o que
posee conocimientos que modifican los
usos de las cosas es decir dos
definiciones perfectamente aplicables a
lo que entendemos por innovación
para ir terminando citaremos a pink que
plantea que han existido cuatro eras en
la historia la agrícola la industrial
la de la información y dice que el siglo
21 es la era conceptual y la era
conceptual la define como aquella en la
que para sobrevivir y eventualmente
triunfar las habilidades requeridas son
cuestiones como la creatividad la
empatía o el trabajo en equipo la
creatividad la empatía o el trabajo en
equipo y eso por definición consiste en
cooperar si no lo haces cooperando no lo
vas a hacer
así que para ir terminando bueno de
hecho para terminar
me permito invitarlos a todos a creer os
esto porque nacemos emprendedores y
nacemos innovadores otra cosa es que el
sistema se ha empeñado porque lo ha
hecho muy bien además en decirnos que no
lo somos pero es mentira para ser
emprendedor y para ser innovador os
invito a que lo hagáis juntos que lo
hagáis en equipo y que compartáis la
información insisto en que el sistema se
va a empeñar en que no lo hagáis pero es
vuestro derecho es vuestro derecho
porque sois personas y por ser personas
tenéis talento y si el sistema no os
deja tenéis que salir ahí fuera y
reclamárselo así de simple que seáis muy
felices gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]